I came into this being open-minded to
the idea that I could possibly find love
what's exciting is that I feel like I
found a person I could spend the rest of
my life with yeah not so much
love is blind stars mark Cuevas and
lauren elsie Shamblin have officially
called it quits and Mark's ex Jessica
batten has something to say about it I
cannot walk out of here after this
entire experience with any regrets with
anything left on sad I cannot leave
anything on the table just a little
refresher during the course of the
Netflix reality dating series mark
struck up a relationship with Jessica
it's so crazy to find someone that
mentally is there you're everything that
I've ever wanted and even proposed but
when it came time to say I do
Jessica quoted this moment from Mary
Kate Nash Lee's 1995 flick it takes two
I know it's gotta be that can't eat
can't sleep reach for the stars over the
fence bold serious kind of stuff right
and broke up with mark right there at
the altar I don't think either one of us
is ready to take this on
anyway after production wrapped mark
started dating LC another contestant on
the show but that all came crashing down
over the weekend after LC reportedly
learned that mark was dating someone
else through a post on Reddit couch a
source tells et that the relationship
was never serious but after LC saw
alleged photos of him with another woman
on a trip she felt betrayed in a
statement to ET LC explained quote mark
and I were casually dating but talked
about remaining exclusive especially
because of Kovan 19 but that's over now
as for mark
he told ET quote I enjoyed spending time
with LC for a few weeks but at no point
were we in an exclusive relationship as
LC confirmed herself I wish her the
absolute best
and guess who had something to say about
all of that yep
Mark's ex Jessica I think it's been
therapeutic honestly when one Instagram
user commented on a post about the
breakup drama alleging that Mark was
sleeping with multiple women at the
studio who trained at during filming of
love is blind
Jessica responded quote Wow news to me I
only know about one there's a lot of
obviously drama coming out of the show
but a source close to mark tells ET that
the claims are not possible adding that
Mark loved Jessica and wanted to marry
her
et has also learned that production on
the show was intense
and cast members were closely followed
by cameras during filming we were in
such a vacuum like we had this intense
situation back in March et spoke with
Jessica and Mark and she opened up about
her decision to leave mark at the altar
during the show's finale after the show
wrapped I had a really tough time I had
you know kind of take some time for
myself and get through therapy and stuff
like that and I feel like I'm having a
fresh start and I feel really good about
where I'm at and you know finally
starting to open myself up again but
wouldn't be able to do that without the
lessons that I learned here and you know
from mark at the time Jessica said she
thought she and Mark would still be
friends we're connected for life so no
one is ever gonna understand how crazy
this woman this is season 1 it's not
like oh the bachelor that's been running
for 17 seasons it's really we had to put
ourselves out there and to sign up for
this you know we were in it together I
mean we're always you're always gonna
have a friend
[Music]